we're asked to simplify the cube root of
27 a squared times B to the fifth times
C to the third power and the goal
whenever you try to just simplify a cube
a cube root like this is we want to look
at the parts of this expression over
here that are perfect cubes that are
something raised to the 3rd power that
we can take just the cube root of those
essentially taking them out of the
radical sign and then leaving everything
else that is not a perfect cube inside
of it so let's see what we can do so
first of all 27 you may or may not
already recognize this as a perfect cube
if you don't already recognize it you
can actually do a prime factorization
and see it's a perfect cube 27 is 3
times 9 and 9 is 3 times 3 so 27 its
prime factorization is 3 times 3 times 3
so it's the exact same thing as 3 to the
third power so let's rewrite this whole
expression down here but let's try it in
terms of things that are perfect cubes
and things that aren't so 27 can be just
rewritten as 3 to the third power then
you have a squared clearly not a perfect
cube a to the third would have been so
we're just going to write this let me
write it over here we can switch the
order here because we just have a bunch
of things being multiplied by each other
so I'll write the a squared over here B
to the fifth B to the fifth is not a
perfect cube by itself but kit can be
expressed as a product of a perfect cube
and another thing B to the fifth is the
exact same thing as B to the third power
times B to the second power if you want
to see that explicitly B to the fifth is
B times B times B times B times B so
this the first three are clearly B to
the third power and then you have B to
the second power after it so we can
rewrite B to the fifth as a product of a
perfect cube so I'll write B to the
third I'm doing that same purple color
so we have B to the third power over
here and then it's B to the third times
B squared so I'll write the B squared
over here we're assuming we're going to
multiply all of this stuff and then
finally finally we have hundreds in blue
C to the third power
clearly this is a perfect cube it is C
cubed it is
see to the third power so I'll put it
over here so this is C to the third
power and of course we still have that
overarching radical sign so we're still
trying to take the cube root of all of
this and we know from our exponent
properties or we could say from our
radical properties that this is the
exact same thing that taking the cube
root of all of these things is the same
as taking the cube root of these
individual factors and then multiplying
them so this is the same thing as the
cube root and I could separate them out
individually or I could say the cube
root of three to the third B to the
third C to the third actually let's do
it both ways
so I'll set take them out separately so
this is the same thing as the cube root
of three to the third times the cube
root I'll write them all in well right
dude let me color code it so we don't
get confused times the cube root of B to
the third times the cube root times the
cube root of C to the third C to the
third times the cube root and I'll just
group these two guys together just
because we're not going to be able to
simplify it any more times the cube root
times the cube root of a squared B
squared I'll keep the colors consistent
while we're trying to figure out what's
what a squared B squared and I could
have I could have said that this is
times the cube root of a squared times
cube root of B squared but that won't
simplify anything so I'll just leave
these like this and so we can look at
these individually the cube root of 3 to
the third or the cube root of 27 well
that's clearly just going to be I want
to do that in that yellow color this is
clearly just going to be 3 right 3 to
the third power is 3 to the third power
or it's equal to 27 this term right over
here the cube root of B to the third
well that's just B that's just B and the
cube root of C to the third cube root of
C to the third well that is clearly I
want to do that in that that is clearly
just C so our whole expression has
simplified to three times B times C
times C times the cube root times the
cube root of a squared B squared times
the cube root of a squared a squared the
squared and we're done I just want to do
one other thing just because I did
mention that I would do it we could
simplify this way or we could recognize
we could recognize that this expression
right over here
can be written as 3 B C to the third
power and if I take three things to the
third power and I'm multiplying it
that's the same thing as multiplying
them first and then raising to the third
power come straight out of our exponent
properties and so we can rewrite this as
the cube root the cube root of all of
this times the cube root times the cube
root of a-squared b-squared and so the
cube root of all of this of 3b C to the
third power well that's just going to be
three BC and then multiplied by the cube
root of a-squared b-squared I didn't
take the trouble to color code at this
time because we already figured out one
way to solve it but hopefully that also
makes sense we could have gone we could
have done this either way but the
important thing is is that we get that
same answer